-All right, well...
-(AUDIENCE CHEERING, APPLAUDING)
...please stop,
we have a big show,
a lot of news to get to.
I'm sure you know the big story,
Joe Biden, our president
went to Israel this week.
Nothing to do with the war,
just wanted a break
from the tension in DC.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
But I think
this was his best week
as President Joe Biden.
-This was his--
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
I think so, his finest hour.
I mean, and then he gets
his ass on a plane.
It can't be easy.
-He's not--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
What? He's not a young man,
he remembers
when the Dead Sea was alive.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
He told the wailing wall
to keep it down.
-No he's not a young man.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
But no, he went there
to give Israel an aid package.
-He's like the world's grandpa.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
He can't visit without slipping
a little money, you know, just--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES)
"Get some missiles,
don't tell Grandma."
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-(CHUCKLES)
But then he came home,
he made a great speech
about Israel.
At the end of it,
they caught this on camera,
somebody else, "Clear,"
and then somebody goes,
"That was great!"
Of course, the bar for great
in the Biden White House
is like if Hunter doesn't wander
in with a hard-on.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-Just to put it in perspective.
-I'm just--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
(CHUCKLES) But here's the thing,
he wants to give all this money
to Ukraine and to Israel.
But we-- (CHUCKLES)
Has to come from Congress
-and we don't have one.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
The House of Representatives,
I'm sure you've known this
for the last 17 days
remains paralyzed
from the neck up.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
The Republicans
control the house.
They want to elect this guy,
Jim Jordan.
Do you know Jim Jordan?
He's from Ohio
with former gym teacher,
I call him Jim "Gym" Jordan.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-(CHUCKLES)
-And he's a--
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
He's what you call
an insurrectionist
insurrectionist,
-you know, he--
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
He's not really
an indoor Republican,
which is troubling
for some of them
because he sends women running
to the other party.
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
He's an election denier,
a conspiracy theorist,
-and a creep.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Or as Matt Gates calls him,
"Dad."
(AUDIENCE LAUGHING, APPLAUDING)
-But-- (CHUCKLES)
-(AUDIENCE APPLAUDING)
But see, the problem
with The Republicans,
is they have just enough
crazy Republicans
to keep a sane person
from getting the job,
and just enough sane
to keep the crazy people
-from getting the job.
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
Ironically, they have
a Mexican standoff...
-(AUDIENCE LAUGHING)
-...in the Republican party.